before we say goodbye we like to play a
quick round up truth or dare
all right so what's it going to be drew
or dare and please say it together
dare okay
all right so we'll do anything yeah we
will all right what's it gonna be so we
love playing games and so we wanted to
challenge you and ross to the junk in
the trunk challenge yeah so we have
tissue boxes filled with ping-pongs
right behind you okay
wait tie them around your waist yeah
just towards the back yes the tissue box
should be in the back okay yeah okay and
then
to tie it drew in the front oh i'm
working on
i like how bossy yeah
i like it keep it coming honey okay so
then you're gonna shake that booty okay
and you have 30 seconds the one who gets
the most out is the winner okay
and we're gonna count you down okay
great ready
two
one
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
all right
i'm telling you i don't think i got any
out you did these are all yours yeah but
how many are in there still can i take a
load
let me see
oh she's got oh hi she's got two four
six seven in there how many do i have
left oh my god i'm so out none
yes
[Music]
good job both of you
well what's it gonna be druth or dare it
is a dare okay
okay now i'm willing to do anything
anything at all yes all right so i do a
little bit of working out i don't do a
lot okay don't have the best upper body
strength so i thought maybe we can share
this experience together i love it let's
do push-ups okay what do you think let's
try it now do you want to do lady
push-ups or do you want to do the actual
push-ups i'll probably go for lady
push-ups all right do you want to do it
together let's do it together cool
okay
all right
[Music]
you feeling it yes
[Music]
do you want to keep going you had enough
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
is it going to be a truth or a dare it's
going to be a dare okay
we've never said no before so bring it
on okay you ready yeah i love sour foods
i dare you to eat a quarter of a lemon
while keeping a total poker face
i love this dare do you have a lemon
someone does
oh oh
we just found some on the desk okay
three two go
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh god i failed
i now want to see more people do this
and see who can and can't because it was
impossible not to make the pickle phase
it's a new tick tock challenge try it at
home try it let's start one let's do it
let's do it right now yeah
lemon face we do
we challenge you to a tick-tock
challenge can you eat a lemon and keep a
straight face
i'll tell you i couldn't do it
[Music]
you